souvent ce matin nos travaux sur la
parentalité dans les outre-mer en commun
par deux délégation la délégation aux
outre-mer présidées par Stéphane Artano
et la délégation droit des femmes
présidée par Annick Bignon comme je le
disais outre les présidents sont
également rapporteurs sur cette
thématique et sachalke et moi-même
victoire jasmin si certains constats en
commun aux différents territoires
d'outre-mer son commun aux différents
territoires d'outre-mer chacun présente
évidemment ses spécificités nous aurons
donc au cours des prochaines semaines
des tables rondes régionales consacrées
à chaque territoire
nous nous intéressons ce matin à la
situation très particulière de Mayotte
qui est à la fois le plus jeune et le
plus pauvre des départements français
c'est d'abord le plus jeune des
départements ce qui justifie son
importance pour nos travaux la moitié de
la population
Ia moins de 18 ans en outre du fait
d'une fécondité élevée la moitié des
familles de Mayotte compte au moins
trois enfants mineurs Mayotte est
surtout comme je le disais le plus
pauvre des départements français les
données de l'INSEE qui a notamment
publié en juillet 2022 une un panorama
sur la situation des femmes à Mayotte
sont éclairantes 77% des habitants
vivent sous le seuil de provoteries
nationales soit 5 fois plus qu'en
métropole avec des flux MIGO à 3
importants venus à 95% des Comores la
moitié des habitants et de nationalité
étrangère et vit dans les conditions
très précaires sans la confort sanitaire
de base voire sans électricité sans être
éligible aux prestations sociales enfin
un quart des femmes de 20 à 54 ans sont
des mers isolées dont 90% vivent dans
une grande précarité
un rapport de six inspections générales
révèlent la semaine dernière par révéler
la semaine dernière par Mediapart et
dont nous avons demandé communication à
la première ministre complète ces
constats à l'armoire en évoquant la
situation des milliers d'enfants mineurs
vivants pour certains sans leurs parents
en risque de dissociation et en
situation de précarité sanitaire et
alimentaire je suis très heureuse
d'entendre ce matin une grande diversité
d'acteurs impliquée dans le soutien aux
familles qui pourront compléter ces
constats et nous livrer leur analyse des
spécificités de la situation mahoraise
et des outils les plus appropriés pour
répondre au mieux aux besoins
considérables des familles et enfants de
Mayotte nous entendons par
visio-conférence
Président Monsieur
idam Ahmed directeur général je laisse
en premier lieu la parole aux
représentant de la caisse de sécurité
sociale de Mayotte donc Monsieur
Philippe ferry vous avez la parole et
vous aurez suivi ensuite par Rémi mosito
comme je l'ai dit au préalable et de
Madame moi soukrari Magic je vous
remercie et je vous laisse la parole
vous m'entendez
je suis entendu oui oui bien sûr bien
sûr alors c'est Monsieur ferry pas
forcément un an pour le moment mais en
cas de pour les en fonction des
questions et bien ils seront amenés à
nous donner des réponses je vous
remercie
tout à fait merci
oui
en préambule
à mes propos
la question de la parentalité est
effectivement traitée par les Caisses
d'allocations familial à les traiter
avec ses partenaires dont bon nombre
sont représentés ici que ce soit l'état
que ce soit le Conseil général que ce
soit des partenaires associatifs
naturellement nombreux étaient essentiel
comme l'UDAF
collectivités locales
tout le monde
participe à des actions autour de la
parentalité
les orientations de la branche famille
sont claires elles finit à travers des
conventions d'objectifs et de gestion
les moyens également ils sont donnés à
travers l'action sociale et Camille
toute quoi la limite
la portée est pion de la caisse de
sécurité sociale de Mayotte et
normalement limité à des enfants des
parents qui vivent en situation
régulière et bien évidemment c'est une
c'est un des difficultés c'est que à
partir du moment où on parle si on parle
de la parentalité et vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure des enfants qui se
trouvaient sans parents
[Musique]
sur le sol Mahorais évidemment nous nous
trouvons par l'esprit même de nos
dispositifs en difficulté pour traiter
même si
à l'image d'autres de d'autres
territoires nous pouvons parfois
conduire des actions d'envergure
ne feront pas forcément de distinguer et
prendront les enfants dans leur
globalité on dira pas toujours et la
Caisse nationale des allocations
familiales n'exigent pas toujours
fonction des territoires puisque je
viens pour ma part de Guyane sur lequel
on a des problématiques également fortes
d'immigration et de famille en situation
irrégulière à partir du moment où les
enfants se trouvent dans un collège dans
un lycée dans une école
la Caisse nationale des familiales est
capable de nous donner une autorisation
pour prendre des enfants dans leur
globalité
voilà voilà mes propos introductifs
je vous laisse nous nous poser des
questions auxquelles répondront bien
évidemment précisément le directeur des
prestations familiales et Madame m'a dit
en tant que responsable action sociale
oui alors donc ce que je propose c'est
que les différents intervenants prennent
la parole et après nous allons passer à
la séquence des questions donc je crois
que vous aviez également reçu un certain
nombre de questions préalables de la
part de la des deux délégations je crois
donc puisque vous avez fait de façon
synthétique donc on va en faire le tour
et ensuite vous allez répondre
évidemment aux différentes questions qui
vous ont déjà été posées mais aussi ici
dans la salle nous avons des collègues
et il m'a co rapporteur également qui
sera amené à vous poser des questions
précises alors je vais tout de suite
passer la parole à Monsieur Nizari Ali
pour l'UDAF je vous remercie et je
remercie madame la Présidente qui arrive
merci beaucoup donc monsieur Nizari Ali
vous avez la parole pour l'UDAF
oui alors madame madame est raffati
c'est vous qui êtes là c'est vous qui
représentez l'UDAF en tout cas le
représentant de l'UDAF pour la parole
le président à tous donc je suis arabe
donc le président s'en excusé parce
qu'il avait un retail la nous rejoindre
en fait parce qu'elle a eu un imprévu
donc il va arriver avec un retard mais
sinon j'ai un autre administratrice qui
est là pour ce qui est de l'UDAF en fait
c'est que l'UDAF comme tous les tous les
départements il y en a autant du DAF que
des départements donc nous sommes la 5e
DAF la toute dernière qui était créée en
2014 et qui effectivement depuis 2015 en
ce qui concerne la thématique comme le
propos c'est que l'UDAF gère différents
services aux familles notamment le
service de médiation familiale avec le
soutien des financeurs qui sont la
caisse de secte social de Mayotte le
Conseil départemental qu'on l'a rappelé
le directeur mais aussi le ministère de
la Justice via la cour d'appel de la
Réunion donc nous avons un service de
médiation familiale nous avons un projet
de service de l'espace de rencontre qui
est en cours d'habilitation et aussi
nous menons en fait différentes actions
à destination des familles et avec le
soutien de la CSM de la caisse de
sécurité sociale de Mayotte nous
assurons la coordination du réseau
d'écoute et d'appui et d'accompagnement
la parentalité le coordinateur rien
auquel sa mission c'est vraiment de
coordonner des différents acteurs qui
interviennent sur la parentalité sur le
territoire parce que nous avons beaucoup
d'acteurs sur le territoire qui
interviennent sur l'axe de la
parentalité auquel il y avait besoin de
de faire la cartographie et savoir qui
fait quoi dans le domaine sur la
parentalité voilà à peu près en fait ce
qui en est donc nous avons aussi
assurant aussi la coordination du schéma
de papel de service ou famille grâce au
soutien et la confiance de la caisse de
sécurité sociale de Mayotte et la
préfecture et aussi des actions liées à
la parentalité notamment sur la
parentalité numérique donc sur l'accès
au droit et la prévention sur les outils
l'usage responsable
du numérique voilà à peu près en fait
les différentes actions que nous menons
sur la parentalité un terme introductif
donc au l'UDAF nous sommes un réseau de
31 associations il y a 31 associations
familiales qui interviennent auprès de
l'UDAF et aussi qui qui interviennent de
la parentalité et aussi une fédération
qui est la Fédération famille rurale qui
fait partie du réseau de l'UDAF voilà un
terme de productif et nous
interviendrons bien sûr sur les
différentes questions qui vont être
posées merci
beaucoup madame qui représentait donc
l'UDAF pour Mayotte et je remercie j'en
profite pour remercier ma collègue
vice-présidente qui m'a remplacé et au
pied élevés très rapidement victoire
jasmin et rapporteur sur le texte donc
on va poursuivre cette table ronde avec
maintenant les représentants de
l'udcsf de Mayotte toujours et
nous vous écoutons
bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis
Madame Espagne la présidente de
l'association
udsfm alors nous de notre côté nous
sommes une association de famille qui
intervient dans toutes les domaines de
la santé l'éducation habitat
environnement loisirs et on intervient
aussi dans toutes les familles quel que
soit leur situation
on est on est là depuis 2015 de la
mobilisation et la souris de nombreux
parents agir pour l'éducation de leurs
enfants et de SFR
un élève la volonté est de faire face au
défi du système éducation récent et
l'insécurité au bord et au sein de
l'établissement scolaire
on est on défend des classes surchargées
les rotations dans les classes le rythme
scolaires défis des personnel absence de
réfectoire des collations non adaptées
aux besoins nutritionnels malgré des
avancées de certains thématiques de
défis restent entiers face à une
croissance
excusez-moi il y en a une mauvaise
connexion ça a coupé
[Musique]
on n'entend pas on vous entend plus
madame la Présidente est-ce que soit
pardon
non ça
bah écoutez là ça fait quelques quelques
minutes une minute max mais peut-être
vous avez bougé quelque chose parce
qu'on était très bien connecté jusqu'à
lors donc je sais pas pourquoi
oui
[Musique]
malgré
une certaine thématique
les dés restent entier face à une
croissance
vous coupez juste l'image et souvent on
arrive à avoir une meilleure connexion
là on vous voit même très flou en
réalité voilà alors reprenez
éventuellement on va peut-être peut-être
avec ça
c'est mieux
[Musique]
c'est mieux là
la connexion est la connexion est coupée
très mauvaise je sais pas si
éventuellement ce que je
éventuellement peut-être essayer de
couper et de reconnecter là c'est c'est
pas bon du tout est-ce que pendant que
vous faites les manipulations
éventuellement je vous propose de donner
la parole à Madame Zaïna bah Ahmed à
roussi pardon directrice territoriale
des séméa de Mayotte et puis on vous
reprendra après en espérant que avoir
retrouvé une meilleure connexion parce
qu'on ne comprenait absolument pas
madame la Présidente ce que vous disiez
on va on passe à l'intervenant suivante
et à vous Madame la Directrice
bonjour tout le monde merci pour cette
invitation donc je suis ainaba Ahmed
alouzi directrice territorial de Mayotte
donc les CBR sont une association de loi
1901 c'est une association d'éducation
populaire donc dans tous les
départements français
y compris l'estomac il existe des CBR
donc les CBA sont créés le 8 mars
1992 nous avons 31 ans aujourd'hui parmi
les actions que développent les CM1
c'est les formations telles que les
formations volontaires
CQP BPJEPS et bientôt djeps et donc il y
a plusieurs actions aussi que nous
venons envers un verre la jeunesse et
toute la population de Mayotte telle que
le point acc écoute jeune qui se traduit
en page et donc nous avons aussi nous
accompagnons les jeunes ambassadeurs de
drogue et des enfants les jeunes qui
sensibilisent les enfants par rapport à
leurs droits et nous avons les tout ce
qui est jeu nous faisons des festivals
de jeux parce que nous sommes aussi
nous créons des jeux d'ici et d'ailleurs
justement en
direction de la population de Mayotte
depuis 2008 nous
œuvrons sur la question de la
parentalité donc la paraltraité est une
question comme majeure et d'où la
nécessité justement des animations en
direction des adultes tout adulte qui
souhaite participer à des aliments la
parentalité nous sommes
présents dans tout le territoire
français dans tous les territoires de
Mayotte
merci
alors on va essayer de reprendre merci
Madame la Directrice on va essayer de
reprendre
l'idée CSF si la connexion est meilleure
je ne sais pas si vous êtes connecté on
va essayer de voir si on vous entend
mieux même si on ne vous voit pas on va
essayer de mieux vous entendre à vous
madame
on est excusez nous on est revenu on a
changé de place très bien là pour
l'instant la connexion est bonne je vous
laisse développer madame
je disais que on intervient dans dans
certains champs élargis qui touchent
toute la semaine des familles Mayotte
mais plus précisément nous intervenons
dans les établissements scolaires c'est
un petit peu soufflé parce que je
marchais vite donc
on intervient
et que nous trouvons on se trouve face à
une croissance
exponentielle et à la population
la rupture du mode de vie du climat
insécurité quotidienne c'est dans ce
cadre à partir de ce constat de terrain
nous la Confédération Syndicale des
Familles impulsent les actions dans le
cadre de l'éducation du logement la
consommation la santé l'environnement
ainsi de suite on a des partenaires
auxquels nous travaillons ensemble on a
une convention signée par le rectorat du
Mayotte le partenaire c'est la
préfecture la CSM aussi via l'UDAF qui
nous représente
et que voilà voilà nos démarches on a
des partenaires locaux les communes on
met des actions de parentalité de
certains communes auxquelles on
travaille ensemble
merci
je vous remercie
madame donc la connexion était nettement
meilleure et donc on va laisser la
parole à nos derniers intervenants qui
sont pour l'association Espoir et
réussite Monsieur Tony Mohamed président
et Monsieur idam Ahmed directeur général
à vous messieurs
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames les présidentes monsieur
sénateur mesdames les reporters madame
messieurs alors la notion de parentalité
à Mayotte prend un sens différent selon
trois éléments le directeur vous
présentera la l'association tout à
l'heure donc je disais que la notion de
parentalité à Mayotte prend son
différent selon trois éléments les
limites de relationnel dans la
parentalité le contenu qui donne sens à
la parentalité dans les rapports entre
les adultes et les enfants et enfin les
évolutions qui ont eu un impact dans le
rapport parental
hier l'enfant est élevé dans un espace
très large il était éduqué par des
parents les voisins le quartier et le
village anti c'était l'enfant de tous
concernant les limites relationnelles il
faut rappeler qu'il existe des
particularités sur la manière de nommer
les membres des familles à Mayotte
et qui permettent toutefois de repérer
des véritables éviers dans les relations
parentales
à titre d'exemple le concept de
cousinage n'existe pas à Mayotte
un cousin ou une cousine a le même titre
est appelé tel un frère ou une sœur
ensuite l'attente maternelle et
l'attente paternelle ont tous
deux un titre qui n'est qualifie
et c'est le cas pour l'oncle paternel
comme pour l'oncle maternelle ainsi que
pour leurs époux et leurs épouses
respectives
enfin il faut retenir le rôle primordial
que joue l'oncle maternelle dans
l'éducation le développement d'un enfant
il est parfois un ami un confident voire
plus parce qu'il est à la fois le modèle
masculin et le plus exemplaire et c'est
lui qui présente et c'est celui qui
représente la mer des l'oncle maternelle
qui parle au nom de l'enfant à la place
de la mer pour les grandes occasions de
la vie circoncision liberté chez les
filles mariage médiation avant divorce
etc
pour ce qui est du contenu dans le sens
que l'on donne à la parentalité
rappelons qu'il y a d'ici là quelques
années lorsque les femmes se marient
très jeunes le premier enfant était
envoyé chez les grands-parents pour
trois raisons essentielles d'abord pour
que celui-ci bénéficie du même modèle
éducatif que ses parents
cela permettait cela permet de rendre
responsable très tôt ensuite pour qu'il
donne l'exemple à ce futur petit frère
ou petite sœur en jouant modèle éducatif
et ses parents le fameux grand frère et
enfin pour finir pour ce qui est de
l'aide à la parentalité qui se fait de
manière continue et permanente entre les
grands-parents et les parents
ces derniers sont dans une démarche
d'apprentissage pour réussir l'éducation
de les prochaines naissances
en outre il faut retenir que l'évolution
démographique que Koné Mayotte durant
ces dernières années à un fort impact
sur le rapport à la parentalité d'autres
facteurs
ont sans doute un incident sur cette
question mais nous allons parler du
facteur démographique et migratoire
puisque l'angle de l'immigration fait
souvent l'objet de plusieurs
interrogations que ce soit sur le champ
médiatique ou politique
plus de 34% des migrés à Mayotte est une
femme en âge entre 15 et 35 ans
donc je répète plus de 34 % des migrés à
Mayotte est une femme
âgée entre 15 et 34 ans
il s'agit d'une personne qui entre dans
un marché
matrimonial et qui en âge de procréer
seulement ces femmes laissent derrière
elle parfois enceinte et au terme de
leur grossesse ou avec un enfant en bas
âge leur famille qui auraient pu jouer
le rôle d'aide à la parentalité et tout
simplement participer au développement
de l'enfant quand la mer se trouve
isolée à Mayotte et dans des conditions
plus indignes que l'on pourrait imaginer
dans notre registre il faut noter aussi
que le Mahorais d'aujourd'hui c'est
quelque au modèle de vie européen
et devient de plus en plus
individualiste et peur ces valeurs
historiques
l'espèce familiale a tendance à forte
mettre du il est passé d'un village à
deux parents
un village à un seul parent
en résumé depuis les années 90
2000 Mayotte est frappé par une
acculturation importante
au-delà de cette acculturation être
parrain en Mayotte et dix fois difficile
qu'à mettre pour lui
et pour bien mener ses restes à ses
responsabilités il est continuellement
confronté par des préalables importants
nos résolus dans le territoire d'un côté
des difficultés économiques sociales
sanitaires environnementale
institutionnel de l'autre côté
en effet handicapé au départ par son
niveau de formation
le parano subit des conséquences d'un
territoire pédovellevé dans plusieurs
domaines et jours on va faire un petit
rappel qui était cité par d'autres
institutions ici
au niveau économique démographique un
taux de chômage à 30% dont 70% chez les
femmes
le plus propre de France une inflation
peut également
70% de demandeurs d'emploi n'ont pas de
diplôme
10900 par an soit la plus grande
maternité d'Europe
20 à 30 enfants par jour le nombre de
naissances
environ plus de 400 habitants
c'est quand 58% de taux d'électrisme 68%
de la population moins de 26 ans ça a
été dit 50% de la population est
étrangère
au niveau des infrastructures manque de
route non existence des transports en
commun
c'est cette dernière année par un
problème de sécurité
un cadre de vie très compliqué
tu ne laissent pas le marrer à
s'épanouir
malgré ces données contextes difficiles
qui rend compliqué les fonctions des
parents certains se mobilisent et
n'hésite pas à s'engager dans de votre
formation
c'est le cas d'une centaine de parents
qui s'adressent chaque année à notre
association espoir réussite que je
préside depuis 9 ans pour s'inscrire
dans nos écoles des parents
un dispositif qui leur permet dans le
cadre de la lutte contre les trismes
d'apprendre le savoir de base apprendre
à lire apprendre écrire apprendre à
compter et échanger avec les autres avec
des objectifs clairs et dentifient
suivre la scolarité et la réussite
éducative de leurs enfants
ils participent à un parcours d'une
durée de 6 mois
qui participe à un parcours d'une durée
de 6 mois sur deux heures par jour du
lundi au vendredi
pour conclure
en plus de subir une forte acculturation
nourrie par l'immigration et l'influence
du modèle européen qui nous fait perdre
nos valeurs historiques basées sur
l'entraide familiale il est plus urgent
de donner les moyens ce département pour
se développer rapidement afin de régler
des préalables importants
problème d'eau d'électricité des routes
sanitaires d'insécurité qui dégrade des
jours un jour le moral et l'engagement
des parents Maoré face à ses
responsabilités pour finir nous passons
au sein de notre association espoir et
réussite que le maillot manquant qui
sépare la prévention de la répression et
l'accompagnement
seulement l'accompagnement ça doit être
une étape inéluctable accompagné d'un
gris de lecture qui tient compte des
potentialités et des faiblesses sur le
rapport à la parentalité conçu sous les
pays de la région je vous laisse mon
directeur compléter mes derniers propos
merci
[Musique]
bonjour madame la Présidente bonjour
chers collègues bonjour monsieur le
sénateur de Mayotte
je me présente à medidam directeur de
l'association Espoir réussite
notre association œuvre depuis 2014 dans
le développement social local de la
population de Mouta Perret qui est un
village de Mamoudzou
notre action se base sur trois levier la
concertation des politiques publiques la
sensibilisation des habitants et aussi
de créer des méthodes de coopération
entre les habitants dans ces méthodes de
coopération aujourd'hui on s'est mis
dans une dynamique de création
d'équipements de la vie sociale pourquoi
on s'est mis dans ce genre de
d'équipement on veut mettre en place ce
genre d'équipements sur le territoire
qui sont des centres sociales ou des
équipements de vie sociale c'est pour
mener vraiment ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui une requin quête pour
culturelle on parle souvent de
reconquête foncière à Mayotte on parle
de reconquête juridique à Mayotte nous
ici espoir réussite on veut mener une
reconquête culturelle on accompagne à
nos bénéficiaires à prendre en main leur
environnement à prendre en main des
enjeux qui correspondent à leur réalité
qui sont l'environnement qui sont leurs
cadres de vie qui sont aussi la lutte
contre les trismes des choses qui les
concerne directement pour pouvoir les
amener sur le chemin de l'intégration de
l'inclusion et de l'appropriation
culturelle c'est ça nos missions que
nous souhaitons mener ici et cette
mission qu'on développe sont partis d'un
contexte local
sur lesquels on pourra développer plus
tard sur vos questions merci
madame la Présidente merci à Monsieur le
Sénateur merci et chers collègues de
cette écoute attentif bien écoutez merci
à vous messieurs pour ces éléments
extrêmement précis que vous avez pu nous
livrer et puisque je suis entouré des
rapporteurs victoires jasmin et El
sachalke je vais peut-être donner la
parole tout de suite à elles à chaque
pour vous interroger vous tout ce qui a
participé à cette table ronde de ce
matin
en salon bien entendu les collègues
sénateurs qui sont aussi dans la salle
et en particulier le sénateur de Mayotte
le vice-président du Sénat
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente cher
Annick à mon tour de vous saluer toutes
et tous et de vous remercier pour ses
propos liminaires introductifs qui nous
permet
de finalement de plonger directement en
fait dans la réalité et je crois que ça
a été très bien présenté à travers les
différents chiffres que vous nous avez
livré et fourni je crois que c'était
aussi important d'avoir cette table
ronde et c'était pour nous un élément
essentiel dans le cadre de des missions
que nous menons sur ce sujet de la
parentalité en outre-mer d'avoir une
table ronde spécifique à Mayotte sur la
situation à Mayotte et
sans trop tarder je vais vous poser
quelques questions
pour justement alimenter cette réflexion
notamment sur la question en fait de la
parentalité nous avons bien compris à
travers vos interventions qu'il y avait
eu une évolution et qui a toujours cette
évolution solutions avec des des
problèmes
divers et variés ont été évoqués la
question de l'eau de l'assainissement de
l'insécurité la question évidemment
migratoire mais on sait à quel point le
rôle de la famille le rôle des parents
et est essentiel et reste et demeure les
premiers éducateurs finalement des
enfants et justement au regard des
différents outils que vous avez mis en
place vous nous avez parlé notamment de
la création d'une école des parents nous
avons pu voir aussi les assises que vous
avez menées je crois en mai 2022 sur la
question de la parentalité au niveau du
Séné de Semea qui portait ses assises
avec des ateliers très divers et variés
dans dans les thématiques est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire finalement quels
ont été les besoins que vous avez
identifié pour que justement les
politiques publiques viennent soutenir
renforcer mais également
encourager justement les parents dans le
rôle premier qui est le leur et
finalement quel est votre regard sur
cette évolution et ce qu'il faut
justement aller vers plus de politique
publique en soutien faut-il mettre en
place une éducation à la parentalité de
manière peut-être plus structurée à quel
moment sous quel modalité donc ça c'est
c'est ma première question et nous avons
vu et ça a été cité notamment à travers
un article qui est paru l'article de
Mediapart et madame la Présidente le
cité dans son introduction
cette délinquance aussi juvénile qui est
une une réalité et cette hausse
alarmante de cette délinquance est-ce
que d'après vous il y a justement un
lien avec
l'encadrement actuel l'aide à la
parentalité et quelles sont là aussi
peut-être d'après vous les
préconisations mais également regard de
votre expérience au regard des
témoignages qui vous sont livrés
quotidiennement qu'est-ce que vous
préconisez justement sur cette question
je vous remercie
merci Madame la rapporteur je vous
laisse vous organiser comme vous le
souhaitez qui souhaitent répondre à
Madame la rapporteur el Sacha
peut-être lever la main comme ça
pas de réponse à la question aux
questions si
à très bientôt
Abdou donc je suis administratrice à
l'UDAF
bonjour madame la Présidente bonjour
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
bonjour les collègues
je pense qu'on propos sur les besoins
être aux parents en maillot aujourd'hui
c'est
c'est savoir jongler sur deux systèmes
éducatifs le système traditionnel et le
système le système métropolitain
occidental ou basé sur la laïcité et le
système traditionnel qui est énormément
basé sur les
sur les aspects religieuses et les
aspects de nos traditions locales donc
c'est vraiment
ce jeu là que les parents sont
aujourd'hui amenés à jouer dessus je
pense que nos collègues de espoirs et
réussites on en parlait tout à l'heure
de cette
de cette évolution là qui nécessite
aujourd'hui que les parents soient à
même de jongler avec les aspects de la
vie
de la vie éducative
occidentale ou républicaine j'ai plutôt
envie de dire et de la vie
traditionnelle et à cela on a quand même
beaucoup de freins ils ont été évoqués
le premier qu'on peut citer aujourd'hui
auquel on est confronté c'est l'accès au
numérique puisque vous avez vu on a
énormément de mal à être connecté
moi-même j'ai été
déconnecté à plusieurs reprises donc du
coup l'accès au numérique est quand même
en frein l'accès Internet on a
des jeunes ou des parents qui sont qui
ont le smartphone mais il y a pas il y a
pas l'accès au numérique il y a pas de
l'éducation numérique beaucoup sont
surtout pour les réseaux sociaux mais
pas forcément pour autre chose donc il y
a aussi toute une éducation à faire à la
fois pour les parents et je me réjouis
de voir que la question de l'école des
parents est revenue parce que c'est une
[Musique]
ce sont des actions qui ont été un petit
peu délaissées et qui méritent je pense
d'être
développé sur le territoire
tellement le besoin est réel notamment
le
l'école en tout cas la pédagogie du
numérique et tout ce qui va derrière la
prévention de la prévention au numérique
on a aussi
à mon sens à développer aussi des
la maîtrise de la langue notamment la
maîtrise de la langue française pour
pour les adultes et pour les jeunes mais
aussi pour les jeunes la maîtrise de la
langue des langues locales puisque les
jeunes ne maîtrisent aujourd'hui ni le
français ni les langues locales donc qui
sont eux-mêmes perdus entre ces deux
langues et entre ces deux ces deux
éducations puisque ils prennent à la
fois des repères sur les valeurs
occidentales et malheureusement souvent
ils ne prennent pas les meilleures
valeurs occidentales puisque l'Occident
a très bonne valeur et
et souvent ils calcule ils se disent que
ce qui se voit sur à la télé mais c'est
l'Occident c'est ce qui c'est
l'éducation qu'il devrait avoir etc et
donc les parents sont confrontés à ce à
cette difficulté de de leur de leur
expliquer que les valeurs locales sont
aussi importantes
ou meilleur que ce qu'il que ce qu'ils
prennent de l'Occident ou qu'est-ce
qu'ils prennent de la télé donc il y a
toutes ces questions là à
développer je pense autour de la langue
de la maîtrise de la langue et de la
valorisation des langues locales
les freins sont liées également à
la non accès je dirais aux
établissements culturels du style
bibliothèque le cinéma les loisirs etc
nous avons
insuffisamment de
d'établissement
et surtout on a aussi une difficulté
d'accès les collègues ont parlé de la
sécurité vous le savez et aussi de la
mobilité donc
je pense que il y a à développer ce
genre de d'établissement pour que la
parentalité la coéducation puisse se
développer autour de d'outils d'outils
de proximité et d'outils culturels
existants
je vois que il y a une collègue qui
souhaite réagir je
oui je souhaitais excusez moi je
souhaitais réagir justement par rapport
à cette question c'est juste pour
compléter les propos qui viennent d'être
exprimé donc l'alphabétisation participe
de manière indéniable alors à
l'autonomisation et au développement
socio-culturel et économique de l'homme
donc tous ceux qui ont la maîtrise de
l'écriture de lecture ont amélioré de
manière considérable leur condition de
vie et de travail et
justement c'est la question aussi qui
doit être accentuée sur l'éducation à la
parentalité l'accompagnement des
familles sur la peau éducation et la
co-construction pour tout ces familles à
Mayotte
voilà
merci beaucoup mesdames est-ce que
quelqu'un d'autre souhaitait apporter
des réponses à Madame la rapporteur ou
sinon on va passer à d'autres questions
directement oui à vous madame
l'UDAF je crois souhaitais s'exprimer
mais on vous entend pas pour l'instant
le micro est fermé
par rapport à l'axe de la parentalité
sur la question en complément de ce
qu'on rapportait les collègues donc et
ce que disait aussi le président
Tony tout à l'heure sur la
responsabilité en fait il faut vraiment
accompagner les parents sur et aussi à
les responsabilités c'est très important
parce que beaucoup se disent aujourd'hui
quand on a connu et ceux qui
interviennent auprès de la Protection de
l'Enfance des enfants du juge les
enfants Les enfants du juge c'est ça a
permis à certains parents de se mettre
en difficulté parce que quand on a fait
venir le droit dans la sphère privée qui
est la famille beaucoup de parents se
sont perdus dans la notion de l'autorité
parentale et ça fait beaucoup plus de
dégâts il y a un réel besoin aujourd'hui
pour qu'on puisse parler en fait comme
le disait les collègues sur la
coparentalité toute structure qui
accompagnerait un enfant ou qui
accompagnerait les les parents de savoir
que il y a de la comparentalité il faut
qu'on fasse avec les parents donc la
co-responsabilisation donc c'est très
important donc l'éducation comme ça a
été rappelé sur on est sur deux systèmes
sur le territoire c'est très important
il y a beaucoup de familles et nous on
le voit dans le cadre de nos services
quand les parents viennent à médiation
familiale où ils suivent leurs actions
de d'accompagnement la parentalité qui
se disent ils sont perdus ils ne savent
plus comment faire et on est beaucoup de
structures qui disent oui les parents
sont démissionnaires sur le territoire
face à l'éducation certains parents
iront là on rencontre des parents qui
sont démissionnaires nous on a beaucoup
plus des parents qui sont démunis qui ne
savent plus comment faire parce que
est-ce qu'ils sont responsables qui fait
alors que nous ce qu'on essaie de de
leur rappeler et ce qu'on doit tous
faire aujourd'hui c'est que l'enfance
n'est pas un jeu l'enfant n'appartient
pas un juge mais l'enfant en fait le
parent on est là pour pouvoir les
accompagner à ce qu'ils puissent des
bons éducateurs en fait des responsables
demain et donc qu'on puisse les
accompagner aussi nos enfants à
fréquenter ces établissements ou ses
structures qui mettent en place des
actions
éducatives ou aussi par l'accès à la
culture donc un réel besoin qu'on
soutient les parents là-dessus et leur
expliquer que ils ont l'autorité
parentale sur leurs enfants tant qu'on
ne l'a pas été retirées donc c'est très
très important c'est là-dessus que je
voudrais soutenir et aussi renforcer qui
a besoin de responsabiliser les parents
face à cette éducation là parce qu'elle
a beaucoup quand même qui se retrouve
démuni aujourd'hui face à l'évolution
merci
merci beaucoup pour ces réponses vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure de l'accès à
la culture je voudrais compléter avant
de passer la parole à notre collègue
victoire jasmin a rapporteur
l'accès aux services publics vous avez
parlé de l'accès à la culture mais
globalement c'est un difficile d'accès
au service public donc est-ce que vous
avez des chiffres d'estimation pour les
prestations sociales par exemple qui ne
seraient pas demandé et auxquelles les
personnes devraient avoir droit est-ce
que vous estimez que ces prestations
sociales doivent être calculées et en
fait aligné sur les prestations de
l'Hexagone ou estimez-vous on doit avoir
un système de différenciation pour les
adapter je vous laisse répondre à cela
et ensuite je passerai la parole à notre
collègue et rapporteur victoire jasmin
et les collègues bien entendu présent en
salle avec nous
pour un petit peu
reprendre vos différentes questions
je vais commencer par en fait pour
revenir un tout petit peu sur les
questions qui étaient posées avant parce
que ça me semble important d'éclaircir
sur les modalités de la parentalité donc
en
métropole et dans les autres domaines
vous avez plusieurs dispositifs
administratifs de soutien à la
parentalité et de mode de garde il faut
savoir qu'à Mayotte tous ces dispositifs
ne sont pas déployés
ou des difficultés notamment à tous les
âges en termes de taux de couverture
pour les crèches on est sur un taux très
faible je pourrais aux alentours de 4%
de taux de couverture quand on est aux
alentours de plus de 50% en métropole le
CMG emploi direct n'est toujours pas
déployé à Mayotte alors que on sait très
bien que les instants maternels c'est un
vecteur le mode de garde individuelle
est un vecteur important pour permettre
de sociabiliser aussi des enfants on a
ensuite un une vraie difficulté par
rapport au périscolaire aujourd'hui la
prestation de service périscolaire n'est
pas déployée à Mayotte ce qui empêche en
fait si vous voulez tous les temps on va
dire annexe d'organiser un petit peu le
tout ce qui est accueil accueil
à LSH sur Mayotte il faut savoir aussi
que les pratiquement toujours en
rotation donc c'est à dire que vous avez
beaucoup de temps en fait ou l'enfant
est livré un petit peu à lui-même en
matière de soutien à la parentalité
c'est pareil on a beaucoup de
prestations qui ne sont pas donc tout ce
qui est lieu d'accueil enfant par an on
en a un ou deux mais on est en
structuration par rapport à ce sujet là
donc ça c'est les premiers éléments
c'est que les dix mêmes dispositifs que
l'on peut avoir en métropole ne sont pas
tous appliqués à Mayotte et ce qui peut
poser des difficultés on parlait tout à
l'heure de j'entendais parler des
centres sociaux des espaces de vie
sociale c'est pareil il faut qu'on
arrive à structurer toute cette filière
là ça c'est un premier point un deuxième
point comme la bien évoqué tout à
l'heure monsieur ferry c'est qui est-ce
qu'on peut accompagner dans nos
dispositifs les prestations familiales
sont définies par des règles des règles
d'attribution qui sont plus sévères
qu'en métropole je prends par exemple le
RSA où on a besoin de 15 ans consécutif
de de résidence à Mayotte pour l'obtenir
voilà donc on a des règles spécifiques à
Mayotte qui expliquent que il y a une
partie de la population qui ne
bénéficient pas aujourd'hui une
prestation familiale
sur sur votre troisième question sur la
on va dire la concordance entre les
droits métropolitains et les droits
mahorés bon sans rentrer dans des
éléments politiques c'est pas du tout
mon rôle on est aujourd'hui à peu près à
50% sur le RSA et la prime d'activité
donc le RSA pour vous donner une idée
pour une personne sans enfant isoler
c'est 293 € par mois
à Mayotte on est en outre-mer donc en
outre-mer on a des coûts de la vie qui
sont plus élevés comme métropole voilà
donc je vous laisserai faire le
rapprochement mais en tout cas on est
sur des montants qui sont bien moindre
question
et qui à mon avis pose des difficultés
quand même sur sur la possibilité en
fait de vivre par rapport à ça ce qui
n'est pas forcément attractif pour
obtenir ces prestations là
voilà un petit peu ce que je pouvais
dire sur sur ces éléments sur les
dispositifs en tout cas en place
merci beaucoup vous souhaitiez compléter
monsieur
je souhaitais pas compléter mais je
souhaitais dire quand même que on a on a
sur ces questions sur la question de la
prise en charge des enfants par les
parents je reviens sur ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure et votre souci par
rapport à l'article de Mediapart on est
assez aujourd'hui au niveau institution
de sécurité sociale je parle bien en
termes de caisse de sécurité sociale on
est assez inopérant face à des enfants
qui sont isolés qui ne restent pas
forcément dans le dans le système
scolaire et surtout qui n'ont pas
forcément d'avenir sur le territoire
sont on a des enfants qui ne trouveront
pas même s'il restait dans un système
scolaire à un moment donné deux
possibilités de quitter le territoire
pour avoir un avenir et ça emporte cette
question d'absence d'avenir parce que
j'ai envie de dire et sans
reprendre le propos de mon directeur qui
disait on n'est pas là on n'a pas un
discours politique mais de choses l'une
ou ces enfants n'ont pas à être sur le
territoire ou ne doivent pas être sur
les territoires ou alors
juridiquement il reste sur le territoire
ils sont sans parents et auxquels il
faut qu'on leur donne un avenir faute
d'avenir on bascule très rapidement dans
la délinquance
merci beaucoup je vais céder la parole à
notre collègue victoire et rapporteur
victoire jasmin et ensuite le sénateur
de Mayotte bien entendu qui a demandé la
parole également
oui merci madame la Présidente je vais
revenir sur
les
députée de Mayotte lors du dernier
congrès des maires et là elle était sur
une des tables rondes concernant la
sécurité et elle a lancé même vraiment
un cri d'alarme concernant les
difficultés
qu'on rencontrait Mayotte
particulièrement concernant les enfants
qui étaient en Iran ce qui était de plus
en plus violent et elle avait
parlé également des attaques de bus de
transport scolaire à cette époque là il
a récemment j'ai constaté que c'est la
situation était encore très réelle il y
a quelques jours encore donc je voudrais
savoir est-ce que cette hausse alarmante
de la délinquance juvénile à un lien
avec les failles de l'aide ou de
l'encadrement actuel à la parentalité et
est-ce que vous avez des préconisations
à faire je voudrais également revenir
sur la structure familiale également
voir est-ce qu'il y a également
des liens avec la répartition du rôle
des parents parce que il y a des enfants
qui sont en Iran ce qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément de parents et sur place à
Mayotte mais il y a des parents qui sont
quand même existants alors est-ce que
vous constatez qu'il y a un lien avec la
façon de procéder des pairs et des
maires à Mayotte quel est l'hypertension
et comment l'expliquer vous voilà je
m'arrête à ce stade je vous remercie
merci je vais peut-être en même temps
laisser la parole
à Mohamed oui
merci
merci madame la Présidente je salue ou
re-salut nos invités de de la Table
Ronde
je n'ai pas forcément de questions parce
que la situation je la connais et
je souhaite vous laisser la primeur de
ces questions mais je voulais insister
auprès de nos invités sur l'importance
de ce moment
nous avons deux délégations du Sénat qui
se réunissent la délégation au droit des
femmes et la délégation aux outre-mer je
pense que vous vous connaissez la
qualité des rapports du Sénat et là la
parole vous est donnée vous femme et
homme du terrain pour faire remonter
les choses les représentants de Mayotte
le font bien évidemment mais mais c'est
l'occasion
d'insister sur les particularités de
notre île et notamment
cette difficulté de basculer
d'une société d'une parentalité
traditionnelle qui fonctionnait
parfaitement à une société
du 21e siècle où on cherche à faire
fonctionner dans un département le plus
le plus jeune département de France les
systèmes de solidarité institutionnelles
et d'autres systèmes qui par rapport à
la société traditionnelle sont sont
importés et tout ça avec avec le poids
de de l'immigration avec le poids de la
démographie donc le moment est et trop
restreint pour faire le tour de la
question mais vraiment je souhaite
insister sur le fait qu'il est important
plus tard de répondre à toutes à toutes
les questionnaire en donnant le plus de
précisions possible parce que vos propos
vont être considérablement pris en
compte pour que le rapport qui sortira
soit traduit en préconisations et la
situation de Mayotte n'est pas celle de
Guyane n'est pas celle de la réunion
n'est pas celle des autres des autres
territoires d'outre-mer donc voilà
vraiment le propos que je voulais
ici ici tenir et j'aimerais quand même
alors poser poser une question que
peut-être mes collègues ne vont pas oser
c'est que
[Musique]
souvent lorsqu'on parle de prestation
sociale
à Mayotte des voix s'élève pour dire ah
non il ne faudrait pas aligner parce que
on ferait un appel d'air par rapport à
l'immigration parce que on déséquilibré
on déséquilibrerait la situation de
Mayotte qu'est-ce que vous femme et
homme du terrain pensez
de cette de cette réflexion
merci monsieur le sénateur donc je vous
laisse répondre à la question de la
rapporteur victoire jasmin et cette
question aussi de notre collègue de
Mayotte qui est évidemment quelque chose
qu'on entend régulièrement merci à vous
la question vous a laissé sans voix
mesdames et messieurs
alors
l'UDAF et ensuite à vous monsieur
président d'espoir et réussite qui
interviendra ensuite
à vous lui DAF oui je vous remercie sur
la question de l'insécurité de l'attaque
et des attaques des bus c'est une
question
très prégnante c'est même un fléau ici
il n'y a pas une journée sans ces
attaques hier même il y a eu des
attaques un professeur a été
a reçu un jet de pierre
au lycée de Monnier
il y a eu des attaques autour de Canny
et il y a eu des attaques à Toulouse ce
sont alors c'est 63 lieux différents
c'est au nord au centre et à Mamoudzou
dans la capitale donc pour vous dire que
il n'y a pas une journée sans sans
attaque de bus sans attaque au jeu de
pierre et c'est cette question de
l'insécurité et aussi lié aussi à la
mobilité puisque
il se trouve qu'il y en a qu'une seule
route ou une
qu'un seul réseau et donc il n'y a pas
il n'y a quasiment pas d'échappatoire
les personnes savent par où les les gens
vont passer et quel que soit leur il y a
plus de ce n'est plus
que ce soit le matin ou l'après-midi que
ce soit les bus ou les personnes
physiques puisque avant-hier c'était
directement les les habitants enfin les
les voitures qui étaient prises pas
forcément les bus donc c'est vraiment
une question qui est qui est cruciale et
et qui impacte tout le monde puisque
même si ça se déroule la Mamoudzou c'est
ce sont des faits qui qui sont faits sur
les personnes qui vont aller travailler
sur Mamoudzou et donc du coup
qu'ils habitent au sud ou au nord les
personnes sont impactées par par ce
fléau
merci la question de la lignement des
prestations sociales oui
quand vous avez parlé de de
l'article de Mediapart cet article
concerne essentiellement les zones
urbains de Mamoudzou de Congo voire de
Granny où il y a une forte une forte
[Musique]
concentration
immigrée mais ne concerne pas forcément
les zones plus reculées où on a on a
moins ces effets là donc du coup je
pense que dans les politiques publiques
il ne faut pas oublier les les zones
reculées les autres les autres
territoires de Mayotte ne pas se
focaliser sur ces questions là qui je
pense justement à un moment donné
exaspère la population puisqu'elle a
l'impression que les politiques
publiques ne travaillent que pour la
question qu'autour de la question de
l'immigration et des immigrés
très bien
Madame de l'UDAF je crois que vous
souhaitiez compléter peut-être
oui
vous entendez d'accord ok donc en fait
ce que je en complément de ce que disait
ma collègue effectivement sur la
problématique de la concentration et la
mobilisation géographique nous ce que
nous disent les familles aujourd'hui
parce que il y a pas de jour sans
attaque aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
c'est que au niveau de l'immigration
c'est que et les attaques en fait
vraiment la délinquance juvénile ce
n'est pas ce que nous subissons tous en
fait en tant que acteur économique en
tant que famille mais ça déstabilise
tout vraiment
on a du mal à recruter aujourd'hui sur
les territoires au niveau de la
problématique à faire de la créativité
parce que les médias montrent auxquels
l'insécurité à Paris on ne montre que ça
et donc du coup pour pouvoir recruter
quelqu'un on peut avoir une année ou
voire même en fait plusieurs entretiens
pour avoir une professionnelle compétent
parce que quand on a des professionnels
qui viennent de l'Hexagone ou qui vient
de l'extérieur ou même des Maoris qui
résident à l'extérieur qui se disent que
pour pouvoir rentrer quand ils ont des
familles comment faire face à
l'insécurité on se lève le matin nous
parce que toute l'activité et les
concentré sur Mamoudzou on s'élève le
matin à 4h30 je vous dis madame la
Présidente mes chers sénateurs à 4h30
quand on vient du centre pour aller
travailler à Mamoudzou alors que nous
sommes des parents est-ce que nous
méritons cela et comment ce qu'on peut
nous dire nous en tant que parents de
concilier avec notre vie familiale et
notre vie professionnelle nous sommes
les premiers éducateurs nous sommes
responsables de l'éducation de nos
enfants on se lève à 4h30 de m'attacher
une pour aller travailler pendant que
nos enfants dorment on passe deux heures
de trajet pour 30 km ce que font Paris
pour aller à Metz en moins on le fait à
une heure 20 nous va passer ce temps là
et à chaque passage on se dit est-ce
qu'on va gagner la vie ou pas sur chaque
carrefour qu'est-ce qui va nous arriver
parce qu'il peut y avoir des barrages il
peut y avoir des caillasses et quand on
arrive on détruit nos biens gratuitement
et ce qui se passe c'est vraiment de la
délinquance gratuite auquel on veut
déstabilisez le territoire et lorsqu'on
se retrouve par an une fois arrivé
affranchir le pas d'arriver au travail
il faut que on se soucie de ce qui se
passe dans les établissements scolaires
nos enfants vont être kayaki vont être
on s'instruit dans les établissements
scolaires les lieux voilà de la
République où on peut assassiner nos
enfants est-ce que les parents mahorés
doivent vivre ça jusqu'à quand et ça
c'est la réalité on ne peut plus se dire
qu'on se dise je suis enfant de où je
suis jeune il faut vraiment dire les
choses un enfant ne tue pas
ce qu'on voit ici c'est vraiment de la
radicalisation des actes radicaux
radical qui se passe dans notre sur
notre territoire aujourd'hui on va
continuer à vivre comme ça jusqu'à quand
et quand on a des pouvoirs publics en
fait quand on a la sécurité on est quand
même la cinquième puissance quand on
arrive qui souffrent à débarrasse les
militaires qui sont là ne font rien
parce que je me suis je viens je me
cagoule j'y arrive je déstabilise tout
toute la route et là qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait on repousse les jeunes les jeunes
sont repoussés on ne sait jamais
qu'est-ce qui était pris des jeunes qui
étaient pris on vient on attaque nos
structures ils sont validées ils sont
cambriolés on nous prennent tout moi je
peux vous dire au niveau de l'UDAF en
une année où nous a cambrioler nos trois
structures on a vantaliser nos véhicules
on nous a pris 17 ordinateurs on a pris
mais vraiment tout et ça ça fait partie
d'une de nos réalités que nous vivons et
derrière tout cela ce sont des jeunes
quand on a eu des photos des images
qu'on a donné à la police ce sont des
jeunes qui se cagoule et on nous
trouvera jamais les responsables nous ça
fait déjà une année depuis une année
depuis 2022 on a commencé avec un
cambriolage on ne vient d'en finir là
trois cambriolages qu'on a eu auquel on
enlève tout mais vraiment derrière il y
a toute une organisation on n'a jamais
eu quelqu'un on ne sait pas qui et pour
qu'on a vu des images et ça c'est très
douloureux on va continuer à vivre comme
ça jusqu'à quand et c'est ça en fait qui
nous fait défaut il est vrai qu'il y a
un réel besoin qu'on puisse
décentraliser l'activité économique à
Mamoudzou pour pouvoir se rapprocher de
lieu de résidence pour qu'on puisse
assurer un certain continuité et que
lorsque il y a des actes de vandalisme
pareil qu'on puisse permettre à
accompagner des familles assouvir une
continuité d'activité
ce n'est pas possible ce que nous
subissons aujourd'hui et en complément
par rapport à ce qu'on disait sur les
aliments effectivement de de des
prestations nous sommes convaincus comme
la rappeler les zones ruraux on a une
intendance en fait aujourd'hui souvent
en fait à montrer comme si la politique
publique elle se concentre que là-dessus
non aujourd'hui les mahorés comme vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure nous
sommes le territoire le plus pauvre de
France nous avons le même besoin que
nous vivons aujourd'hui au 16 mars 2023
les Maoré ont les mêmes besoins que ce
qui se passe à Paris malheureusement
nous avons un retard de plus de 50 ans
les conditions d'éligibilité c'est ce
qui nous fait défaut nous avons des
familles ou même aussi bien qu'ils sont
retrouvés face au RSA ou aux différents
prestations auxquelles la loi en fait la
réglementation tant qu'elle ne sera pas
changée nous sommes en maillot
aujourd'hui en 2023 le code de la
sécurité sociale ne s'applique pas
encore à ma gueule comment faire on ne
peut pas nous quand on accompagne des
familles se retrouver un moment donné la
réalité ne nous permet pas de vous
pouvoir vous accompagner nous avons des
personnes qui sont d'origine étrangère
qui vivent à Mayotte parce que la la
culture administrative n'existait pas on
a des familles que nous accompagnons qui
habitent à Mayotte qui sont d'origine
étrangère qui habite à maillot de plus
de 30 ans ils n'ont jamais pu eu le
besoin de régulariser leurs situations
administratives ils se retrouvent
aujourd'hui qu'ils doivent régulariser
ceux-là malheureusement ils n'ont pas
droit aux prestations parce qu'il faut
vivre à Mayotte justifier de 15 ans de
titre de séjour alors que
malheureusement on a la formation ils
ont des enfants qui les ont eu à Mayotte
donc on ne peut pas les accompagner ça
ça fait partie de la réalité donc on a
besoin de pouvoir
adapter vraiment par rapport aux
spécificités parce que nous sommes
convaincus le fait de dire que lorsqu'on
va mettre en place en fait l'alignement
sur les droits des droits sociaux ça va
appeler ça va faire un appel d'air ça
c'est faux nous savons tous que il y a
des conditions d'éligibilité d'une
famille qui a un enfant en situation
d'handicap ou d'une famille qui vivent
en très grande précarité a besoin de
trop soutenu ils nous ont il aura il
aura l'aide qu'il faut ce ne sera pas la
même qu'une personne qui se retrouve qui
travaille mais qui qui a le RSA et qui a
des enfants avec cet enfant dont
certaines sont en bas âge et il n'aura
pas les mêmes droits donc il ne faut pas
qu'on nous dise que demain aurait ou la
population mahoraise qui habite à
Mayotte
n'a pas besoin parce qu'il y a un appel
d'air nous sommes convaincus que il y a
des conditions d'éligibilité et
lorsqu'on va piquer juste la loi et
qu'on améliore cela ça va aider beaucoup
de familles nous avons des familles
mahoraises aujourd'hui qui vivent dans
le droit local
et face à l'accès ou RSA on leur fait
part en fait de droit commun alors que
ils ont des conjoints qui sont de
retraités parce qu'ils sont mariés en
droit local on leur dit que vous n'avez
pas droit au RSA parce que quand une
famille mahoraise par rapport à la au
système que nous avons culturel et bien
sûr du droit commun ces familles là son
marié en droit local mais il y a aucun
acte de mariage et ils sont bloqués
parce que leur conjoint vive avec leur
retraite de misère comme vous le savez
ce qui se passe et c'est conjoint là
auquel on tient compte des ressources
ces ressources ne sont pas utilisées sur
le foyer le le père retraitée ils vivent
avec les ressources qui sont utilisées
ailleurs et ils ne contribuent pas aux
charges de la famille et donc c'est une
grande difficulté vraiment qui met à mal
le cadre de vie et le bien-être aussi
des familles mahoraises donc un rêve
besoin aujourd'hui un rêve besoin qu'on
puisse aligner les droits sociaux parce
que nous avons un réel besoin
merci
ben écoutez merci pour la clarté de la
réponse que vous avez apporté au
sénateur
local qui est avec nous ici au Sénat à
Paris puisque votre réponse était claire
et précise sur appel d'air ou pas appel
d'air c'est donc qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'appel d'air si les conditions
d'accessibilité aux prestations sociales
évoluaient donc merci à vous pour ces
différentes réponses moi je vais
peut-être compléter cette matinée avec
une question peut-être d'abord un peu
plus générale sur
comment l'organisation entre les
associations et les services de l'État
est-elle une organisation fluide et
est-ce que les associations
bénéficient de moyens suffisants à la
fois financier et en Ressources Humaines
vous y avez déjà en partie répondu
lorsqu'on a des difficultés de
recrutement et des difficultés de
délinquance et de sécurité tout à
l'heure mais est-ce que vous vous
travaillez véritablement en coordination
association services de l'État et les
moyens alloués aux associations sont-ils
finalement pérenne suffisamment pérenne
pour faire face aux missions qui sont
les vôtres une deuxième question pour
terminer peut-être sauf si quelqu'un
souhaitait compléter sur peut-être la
caisse de sécurité sociale qui pourrait
répondre sur ses prestations sur leur
alignement par rapport à l'Hexagone sur
des prestations aussi peut-être qui
devrait être différenciées parce qu'il y
a la possibilité d'alignement mais il y
a aussi la différenciation qui pourrait
être possible puisque vous l'avez
spécifié
vivre dans un territoire ultramarin et
vivre à Mayotte évidemment le coût de la
vie les conditions pour venir aussi
rejoindre
l'Hexagone pour bénéficier d'autres
services publics ça a un coût donc
comment
imaginez-vous
du point de vue de la caisse
ces réponses je vous remercie
oui bonjour
vous allez en premier ou on y va
comme vous voulez
alors
sécurité sociale d'abord et puis après
il y a je crois qu'il y avait
l'association qui souhaitait intervenir
à vous monsieur
je vais prendre la parole sur la partie
prestation pour les actions
sociales et puis directeurs complétera
sur la partie alignement des
prestataires
comme je disais tout à l'heure en fait
il faut bien avoir en tête pour les les
associations les partenaires c'est que
on n'a pas les prestations de service
national qui sont déployées à Mayotte et
donc qui dit déploiement des prestations
de service national empêche en fait un
petit peu cette structuration et cette
pérennisation dans le temps des fonds
c'est-à-dire que en métropole voilà vous
avez un périscope qui fonctionne et tous
les ans il fait ses déclarations et ça
fonctionne ainsi ici Ahmed c'est
toujours sur une logique d'appel à
projet donc c'est vraiment un besoin
fort de déployer les prestations de
service à Mayotte pour pouvoir
pérenniser les financements aux
partenaires
alors pour compliquer
votre votre propos
nos moyens je parle là pour la sécurité
sociale nos moyens sont calculés sur la
base d'une population
qui réside régulièrement sur le
territoire
à travers tous les échanges que nous
avons eu et ça vaut saut en tous les cas
pour les territoires d'outre-mer soumis
à forte immigration
nous sommes nous sommes handicapés par
cette règle
nous sommes handicapés d'une part par
cette règle et d'autre part par une idée
qui est à mon avis est fausse mais qui a
été rappelé par les par les intervenants
nous sommes en tous les cas avec la
Guyane et Mayotte et la Guyane nous
sommes sur des territoires qui sont en
développement ce sont des territoires en
rattrapage et là où la métropole
dans les années 50 avait des modes
d'intervention ou laisser à la sécurité
sociale des modes d'intervention
originaux
on applique en applique à nos
territoires
des modes d'intervention
à l'aune de ceux de métropole c'est à
dire que quel que soit le domaine dans
le domaine de la santé dans le domaine
de l'action sociale dans le domaine des
moyens accordés à la sécurité sociale
[Musique]
de plus de gens pour développer on
parlait tout à l'heure des centres
sociaux en parler des de tout ce qui
participent à la cohésion sociale et
bien à partir du moment où on doit
développer ces centres sociaux
développés des actions au sein de ces
centres sociaux ça nécessite plus de
moyens qu'à Lille ou la culture des
centres sociaux a déjà été développé
mais a été développé sur déjà une
trentaine d'années 30 35 ans 40 ans et
donc vraiment j'insiste sur cette
spécificité des organismes d'outre-mer
qui doivent répondre à des objectifs
convergence de droits qui doivent aussi
répondre à des questions de rattrapage
et qui doivent répondre à des défis qui
sont parfois hors normes voilà même la
Présidente je passe la parole à notre
responsable action sociale
bonjour à tous et à toutes donc en fait
moi je voulais réagir sur la question de
coordination entre les acteurs
d'abord revenir sur le fait sur
l'évolution confirmée aussi l'évolution
faite de la structure familiale au
niveau de notre territoire à savoir
l'évolution grandissante des familles
monoparentales donc une responsabilité
qui repose sur le rôle de de la femme
mahoraise une recomposition familiale
également et des structures familiales
composées d'une personne âgée et des
jeunes femmes donc un décalage d'âge qui
engendre aussi des difficultés dans
l'éducation de des enfants ceci aussi
contribue bien évidemment à cette
évolution à ces difficultés en matière
d'éducation pour les éducation pour pour
les jeunes sur le territoire
je voulais revenir également
quand on vous avait parlé de
coordination au niveau de la caisse de
sécurité sociale nous avons un document
phare un document socle sur le
territoire qui est le schéma
départemental des services aux familles
bien évidemment l'enjeu est de
travailler ensemble entre les
différentes acteurs les acteurs de
l'État les acteurs des collectivités
les communes les structures associatives
qui ont toutes leurs places pour
partager remonter les besoins les
difficultés au niveau des territoires
sur les différentes axes qui
répondent du coup au service des
familles dont également l'axe de la
parentalité ou l'enjeu majeur ici et de
coordonner les acteurs qui interviennent
dans le cadre de la parentalité un accès
par l'UDA et la dette bien évidemment
sous l'égide de l'État avec un rôle
central de la caisse de sécurité sociale
de Mayotte je confirme également les
difficultés quand on parle d'un il y a
les moyens financiers et à les
ressources humaines globalement ce qu'on
ce qui se relève au niveau du schéma
départemental des services aux familles
on constate également des difficultés
sur la des moyens financiers puisque
aujourd'hui je dirais que la caisse de
sécurité sociale contribue vraiment à
plus de 60% en tout cas des besoins du
territoire sur la sur l'action sociale
cependant il y a une difficulté donc de
cofinancement qui est constaté et là
effectivement il y a un gros souci
puisque au niveau de nos collectivités
les communes aujourd'hui ont des
difficultés à co-financer les actions
des structures associatives ou bien le
département ce qui fait que aujourd'hui
je pense que les les collègues vont le
confirmer ou
vont confirmer le la grosse difficulté
c'est que malgré que la caisse de
sécurité sociale amène des moyens ils
arrivent toujours ils arrivent pas
forcément à mettre en réaliser leurs
actions faute de co-financement par les
autres
partenaires donc ça aussi c'est une
difficulté réelle sur le territoire
qu'il faut qu'on accompagne la
professionnalisation des différentes
partenaires sur le territoire
et aussi qui qui engendre en tout cas un
gros tourneur et qui empêche du coup nos
structures à être pérennes pour réaliser
toute l'accompagnement envers les
familles
jour merci messieurs et Madame pour ces
réponses et donc c'était le
l'association Espoir et réussite
monsieur le Président qui souhaite
intervenir je crois
oui
bonjour c'est plutôt le directeur qui
pardon madame je vous avais pas vu je
vous donne la parole en suite oui je
souhaitais intervenir notamment sur la
question de la structure parentale sur
la question de la prestation sociale qui
a évoquée
sur les moyens à louer aux associations
sur la structure familiale à Mayotte on
peut dire que la famille
est sur deux axes à Mayotte elle est sur
un axe de Matri localité ou le foyer
conjugal et placer à sous l'égide de de
la mer où le foyer conjugal et du côté
de la mer et aussi étonnant que ça
puisse l'être
c'est aussi elle est aussi dans un axe
de Matri matriarca de fille pourquoi je
dis matriaka de fille alors que à
Mayotte on sait tous que la région la
majorité de la population est musulmane
et la région musulmane ce qui prime
c'est le patriarcat donc tout ça ça se
définit dans la pratique dans des
pratiques et dans une économie des
familles qui se déroulent sur le
territoire la femme se retrouve seule
avec les enfants soutenus avec les
membres de sa famille et de la
communauté et l'absence passif du père
n'a jamais été un problème dans dans
notre société puisque la mer avait la
sécurité de la famille
mais aussi la sécurité de la famille au
niveau économique
du fait de de ces structures matries de
matrilocarité et le soutien des
institutions communautaires qui
s'occupaient de l'éducation de des
enfants que ça soit les shony que ça
soit les écoles coraniques qui étaient
sur place qui accompagnait la mère qui
qui a éduqué ses enfants et cette
absence de père passif n'a jamais été un
problème et souvent les grandes
décisions sont souvent prises par la mer
en témoigne en témoigne le mouvement des
chatouillesuses pour pour que
Mayotte reste dans le gérant français
cette mise en avant de de la femme
aujourd'hui cette
nomadé du père s'ajoute à d'autres
phénomènes qui ont des conséquences sur
le rôle et l'articulation des familles à
Mayotte
un couple sur deux et mixte c'est-à-dire
que
une personne dans le couple n'est pas
natif du territoire
ce qui engendre une mixité
quand on dit quand la mixité est
engendrée forcément il faut que le
couple trouve des moyens modernes parce
que la mixité engendre forcément la
modernité il faut que la famille le
couple trouve des moyens modernes
d'éduquer leur enfant et c'est souvent
là que ça pêche que les parents
n'arrivent pas à trouver un équilibre la
deuxième
la deuxième influence et l'immigration
massive l'immigration massif de femmes
qui viennent avec des enfants en bas âge
ou qui viennent accoucher sans être dans
une structure familiale équilibrée parce
qu'il y a ni la famille de la femme à
côté il a mis le père souvent il y a ni
les soutiens parental la grand-mère le
grand-père à côté est-ce qu'il a créé
des déséquilibres et des éclatement de
la famille
dans le même temps la modernité et la
culture occidentale 1000 min un peu plus
la culture locale qui compenser ces
phénomènes de ce phénomène de d'absence
passive du père je crois sincèrement ce
que si on avait valorisé nos pratiques
culturelles éducatives fondées sur la
solidarité qui ne sont propres on aurait
pu on aurait pu encaisser le choc
démocratie démocrative démographique et
culturelle qui qui nous frappe
aujourd'hui
parce que aujourd'hui quand on regarde
les politiques qui se qui sont menées au
niveau de la métropole c'est des
politiques publiques qui veulent
justement retourner sur la solidarité
que nous on avait comme fondement ici
sur le territoire la solidarité
communautaire qui sont portées par des
associations et aujourd'hui ces
associations là qui sont au niveau local
il faut qu'on leur donne les moyens d'y
arriver aujourd'hui
je prends l'exemple de notre association
nous une association on a plus de cette
permanent cette salarié en CDI on a plus
de 4 personnes en contrat à durée
déterminée longue durée et aujourd'hui
on a aucune convention plus réelle
signée avec les partenaires malgré le
soutien le soutien de l'État le soutien
de la Caisse de Sécurité sociale le
soutien des collectivités locales avec
lesquelles on travaille depuis plus de 7
ans
aujourd'hui il est compliqué pour nous
d'avoir une perspective de développement
sur plusieurs années puisque nous notre
perspective s'arrête sur une annualité
qui qui freine notre développement
voilà et sur la question de la
prestation sociale à Mayotte je
souhaitais répondre à Monsieur de
sénateur Tani c'est que
personnellement nous on préconise que
les prestations sociales soient
appliquées sur le territoire toutes les
prestations sociales aujourd'hui on a
l'avantage parce que moi j'appelle ça
une avantage d'avoir un seul organisme
de sécurité sociale qui est
multi-branche on peut on peut emmener à
créer une prestation unique qui regroupe
toutes les prestations sociales
existantes
et il serait beaucoup plus facile de
communiquer dessus d'être plus proche de
la population en ayant des relais
locaux qui peuvent justement contribuer
à accompagner cette mise en place d'une
prestation unique qui peut regrouper
toutes les prestations qu'on peut
retrouver en métropole aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment une chance que la sécurité
sociale de Mayotte soit un organisme
unique
merci beaucoup monsieur donc pour une
dernière réponse je passe la parole à
l'UDC SF qui avait demandé la parole à
vous madame
merci madame la Présidente merci le
sénateur de Mayotte monsieur Tani de
nous avoir invité sur cette table ronde
tout simplement je vais démontrer
comment nous travaillons sur le terrain
par rapport au moyen alloué sur les
associations en fait déjà nous avons
identifié que la question de sécurité
question qui nous préoccupe sur les
territoires mahoraires donc du moment où
nous travaillons devant les
établissements scolaires nous udssm a
vomi en place un projet qui s'appelle
habitat en action habite en action c'est
de pouvoir
identifier les fouteurs de troubles et
de pouvoir faire
une action de prévention à la
parentalité
on travaille en partenariat avec
l'État le service de l'État et certains
communes qui sont qui nous accompagnent
dans leur commune par exemple on a mis
en place depuis à 20 DC au nord des
jeunes au nord il y a 2 ans on a mis
notre action aux cité du Nord on l'a mis
à Kani on l'a mis on l'a mis à Sada il
veut partout je peux pas tout citer mais
on milite sur cette action là et que
nous comment on fonctionne pour avoir
des moyens pour pouvoir accompagner avec
l'État on a eu quelques contrats venant
de la préfecture mais il reste à
travailler avec les communes certains
communes nous accompagnent certains
communes nous accompagnent pas donc
c'est un sujet vraiment majeur auquel
nous travaillons à nous nous
fonctionnons avec des appels à projet et
vous savez très bien comment ça
fonctionne les appels à projet on répond
aux appels à projet il faut attendre
encore trois à quatre mois pour
nous répondre que si on a été retenu ou
pas c'est même pas sûr au lieu de
pouvoir
identifier que cette action mène des
vrais actions sur le territoire et de
pouvoir faire des vraies conventions
avec ces axociations là pour pouvoir par
exemple
le renouveler au moins deux à trois ans
le maximum on est en train de bricoler
pardon excusez-moi du terme mais ont
vraiment on bricole sur
nos actions mais la volonté de la
population ou bien des associations
mahoraises on est là à pouvoir trouver
des solutions comme vous le dites le
service de l'État l'affaire de
l'insécurité c'est l'affaire de tous
on s'implique nous les associations et
tout le monde s'implique aujourd'hui ce
que nous souhaitons merci Monsieur notre
sénateur de nous avoir associé et on
pense qu'on aura des réponses par
rapport à cet accompagnement on attend
juste qu'on soit accompagné parce que
tout a été dit tout a été dit parce que
on est confronté à travailler avec tous
les jours des nouveaux arrivants sur les
territoires je mets en cause de rien du
tout c'est le système qui est fait comme
ça parce que on est le seul il le
français qui est autour des îles qui
sont à côté ou bien régional on est
obligé de chercher la France mais tout
simplement nous cherchons des
accompagnements des vrais
accompagnements et de pouvoir
identifier quels sont les associations
qui travaillent vraiment très lourdes
dans cette situation je vais donner un
exemple par exemple avec tout la
violence vous connaissez pas les
territoires mais c'est à Nîmes notre
sénateur va vous expliquer on a la
commune de Mamoudzou en un quartier qui
s'appelle du Janis c'est l'entrée tous
les jours il y avait des conflits il y
avait des caillassages de bus on a
auditionné pourquoi ils sont entrés de
caillasser ils nous ont dit nous avons
constaté cinq questions de jalousie il
est en train de détruire les biens tout
simplement parce que ils voudront être à
la place mais ils arrivent pas à être à
la place donc aujourd'hui on a mis en
place ces actions qui fonctionnent très
bien depuis 2021 notre association et là
il y a eu zéro caillassage et je peux
pas vous dire comment on a été
accompagné c'est difficile je dénonce
pas qui ou bien qui mais nous
association nous avons pas assez
d'accompagnement pour pouvoir mener nos
calcium donc
on aimerait bien que nous on soit
accompagnés par vous les les
infrastructures les services de l'État
ou bien des services
de la commune de la politique quand je
parle de la politique ce sont les élus
aujourd'hui qui puissent vraiment
se mettre ensemble pour pouvoir avancer
mais ensemble on va y arriver et une
seule chose je ne sais pas si ça peut
fonctionner c'est le système de justice
comment on appelle ça coopération
régionale au niveau du justice ça serait
vraiment bien parce que Mayotte on sait
que on a un seul infrastructure qui peut
pas accueillir tout le monde donc là
dessus on demande que si on peut
accompagner cette
cette coopération régionale pour voir
travailler avec les homologues ça serait
vraiment un super idée
donc nous tous les jours comme l'a dit
Luda fait tout et d'autres tous les
jours nous on dort pas on est affecté
psychologiquement des responsables des
associations je dirais pas moi seul mais
nous tous on est affecté
psychologiquement vous avez parlé de
trajet moi je parle même pas de trajet
mais de notre vie familiaux en tant que
responsable on n'a pas de vie on dort
pas on est réveillé comme deux jours et
comme de nuit on est des éléments ciblés
quand je dis ciblé parce que on est le
premier être dans le rang et ces gens-là
nous cherchent ce sont la réelle du
terrain et nous on a même pas devis pour
vivre par exemple on nous appelle on
doit chercher des moyens où on doit
gérer des conflits donc la parentalité
c'est un vrai question du moment où je
conclus par ce moment où on a des
naissances à tous les jours on a une
classe qui se laisse même plus
maintenant plus de salle de classe qui
se naissent sur le territoire sans
compter les flux massif qui rentre dans
notre territoire ça c'est un vrai sujet
donc on va peut-être dire que on va
chercher des solutions d'urgence je
demande au nom de l'UDCM de chercher des
solutions d'urgence de chercher des
solutions à moyen terme de chercher des
solutions
à court terme pour pouvoir vraiment
pallier parce que si on continue à
fonctionner dans cette système il y aura
des vraies conséquences
qu'on pourrait pas traiter à long terme
merci
merci beaucoup madame pour avoir parlé
avec conviction et avec votre votre cœur
aussi pour nous faire comprendre ici au
Sénat
la situation et la situation compliquée
dans laquelle vous êtes vous avez tous
reçu un questionnaire lorsque vous avez
été convié à participer à cette table
ronde de communes entre la délégation au
territoire ultramarins outre-mer et la
délégation droit des femmes ce que je
vous encourage à faire c'est
éventuellement si vous souhaitez
compléter les réponses que vous nous
avez apportées ce matin à répondre à ce
questionnaire à nous envoyer vos
réponses par mail et bien entendu elles
seront intégrées à notre réflexion moi
je j'estime que cette table ronde
organisée par nos deux délégations et le
territoire de Mayotte était extrêmement
importante déjà de le faire et
extrêmement intéressantes à travers tous
les témoignages que vous avez pu
dont vous avez pu nous faire part je
remercie sincèrement aussi évidemment
les rapporteurs pour leur présence et la
vice-présidente victoire jasmin pour
avoir pris la présidence en attendant
mon arrivée et je le sénateur évidemment
Mohamed Tani Souali Tani Mohamed à
chaque fois j'ai un problème avec les
noms de famille je fais un mélange donc
c'est un méli-mélo merci à tany pour sa
présence et éventuellement mesdames et
messieurs je vous encourage parce que
vous avez évidemment un sénateur qui
connaît bien votre territoire à lui
faire part de vos remontées également
comme vous allez en faire part à la au 2
délégation puisque il est là bien
entendu pour répondre à vos attentes
également donc sincèrement merci au nom
des rapporteurs pardon à Tani d'avoir
mélangé mes trois trois pour le prix
d'un c'est compliqué voilà donc merci à
vous mesdames et messieurs on a compris
qu'il y avait urgence comme le disait la
rapporteur victoire tout à l'heure nous
avons des témoignages il y a des crises
d'alerte et ce que vous nous avez donné
comme élément première élément de
réponse et vos témoignages sont
importants parce que parfois lorsqu'on
connaît moins bien votre territoire on
peut imaginer que les informations qui
circulent et notamment l'appel d'air la
question très directe qui vous a été
posée par Dany et la réalité donc vous
avez eu le mérite de nous apporter à une
question claire une réponse claire et je
vous en remercie donc je vous souhaite à
tous et à toutes une belle journée et
merci vraiment des réponses que vous
pourrez compléter avec le questionnaire
qui vous a adressé et je vous remercie
au nom bien entendu également du
président de la délégation outre-mer
Stéphane Artano qui rejoint son
territoire et qui doit être au-dessus de
l'océan à l'heure qu'il est donc
il prendra connaissance de vos réponses
au moment du compte-rendu merci à tous
et bonne journée
merci beaucoup